halo hat es gestern die exklusive
nachricht über steinmeier und jetzt also
steinmeiers ausladung oder dass er nicht
kommen sollte du kannst es besser
erklären als ich wie ist die lage jetzt
wie sieht es aus mit frank walter
steinmeier ist es auch eine these
mitgebracht
janina die situation um falk walter
steinmeier ist weiter eskaliert so kann
man es sagen denn heute sind vier
präsidenten angekommen unter anderem der
polnische präsident zusammen mit den
baltischen
staatsoberhäuptern und da wollte frank
walter steinmeier eigentlich mitfahren
durfte er aber nicht offenbar hatte er
noch versucht dann auch die anderen dazu
zu bewegen nicht zu reisen um nicht
völlig brüskiert dazustehen frank walter
steinmeier hat das flugzeug zurück nach
berlin genommen aus polen und in
deutschland ist wieder die übliche moral
debatte entbrannt aber nicht darüber ob
wir möglicherweise fehler gemacht haben
im umgang mit der ukraine ob frank
walter steinmeier fehler gemacht hat
nein nein nein wir deutschen sind ganz
sicher das war böse von siemens geht das
hätte nicht passieren dürfen das war ein
riesen riesengroßer fehler und wir
beschäftigen uns mal wieder vor allem
mit uns selbst es geht uns wieder nur
darum was ist mit deutschland und wir
reden viel zu wenig darüber dass hier
täglich täglich weiter menschen sterben
in kiew wo ich gerade bin ist es
momentan ruhig aber an mario pohl
sterben weiterhin jeden tag menschen ist
droht eine riesen offensive im osten und
ich finde es typisch für deutschland
ganz unabhängig davon dass man sagen
kann dass das von seelands die
vielleicht nicht so klug war ihnen da
mehr oder weniger auszuladen so wie ich
das gestern ja auch gesagt hat aber ganz
unabhängig davon beschäftigen wir uns
seit 24 stunden damit selbstmitleid mit
deutschland zu haben und mitleid mit
frank walter steinmeier zu haben anstatt
darüber zu sprechen was hier die ukraine
jetzt dringend braucht nena und das sind
waffen
pauli würde ich den direkt gerne noch
eine rückfrage stellen unser
bundeskanzler olaf scholz hat ja auch
gesagt dass er etwas irritiert darüber
sein dass frank walter steinmeier nicht
in die ukraine reisen sollte wie sieht
es denn jetzt mit seinem besuch aus weil
der stand ja auch noch aus
beziehungsweise die einladung von
siemens soweit ich weiß
ja sie lenski wollte dass bundeskanzler
olaf scholz hierher kommt denn er sagt
scholz entscheidet über waffen und
traditionen mit dem musik reden mit
frank walter steinmeier werde ich
irgendwann reden das muss aber jetzt
nicht sein das mag wie gesagt alles
taktisch unklug gewesen sein aber noch
einmal der mann und ich habe ihn ja
mehrfach getroffen die in den
vergangenen zwei monaten
der ist dort im tunnel der schläft im
bunker der schläft nur drei bis vier
stunden und der hat eine riesengroße
angst dass die zweite offensive
russlands nämlich im osten sehr viel
erfolgreicher sein könnte als in kiew
dass dort die waffen die man jetzt hat
nicht reicht und deswegen hat er gesagt
moment mal deutschland schickt uns nicht
genügend waffen deutschland macht diese
sanktionen nicht mit warum soll ich
jetzt ausgerechnet denjenigen empfangen
der ja für diese russland politik stehen
noch einmal das ist jetzt meine
interpretation das hat er nicht
öffentlich gesagt hat sich noch gar
nicht dazu geäußert aber das ist das was
die gedanken hier sind in der ukraine
und ich finde wir sollten in deutschland
jetzt ganz schnell aufhören diese moral
und selbstmitleids debatte zu führen
sondern ganz schnell dazu kommen zu
sagen wir wollen wir das jetzt wieder
aus machen wir halt den ersten schritt
das ist doch egal mein gott es geht hier
um einen krieg und es geht um
menschenleben frosch imke wie sie stehen
sie dazu zu dieser moral debatte die
brawns hermann ja das ist natürlich
wieder typisch deutsch ich wundere mich
dass frank walter steinmeier überhaupt
diese anfrage an die ukraine gestellt
hat dort zuerst hinzu kommen denn wir
wissen um seine vergangenheit wir wissen
er war kanzleramtsminister wir wissen um
sein verhältnis zu russland das wir
zurzeit aktiv wurde diskutieren in den
medien und in der öffentlichkeit und die
fragen sind noch nicht beantwortet
welche rolle er eigentlich tatsächlich
spielt in diesem ganzen drama das wir
zurzeit erleben und insofern ich finde
das kann man sogar als provokation
verstehen dass gar frank walter
steinmeier der erste ist der see lenski
besuchen weil du nicht kannst lenski
voll verstehen da geht es um alles da
geht es um leben und tod die
interessieren sich nicht dafür ob da
jetzt der bundespräsident kommt oder
nicht nein die wollen den wollen
geholfen werden ja und nicht provoziert
werden und nichts zu irgendwas gezwungen
werden worauf sie keine lust haben ich
kann das absolut nachvollziehen ich muss
sagen ich kann das absolut gar nicht
nachvollziehen aber ich mache jetzt
gleich auch erst mal die runde ich finde
das mit damit dass frankreich steinmeier
nicht empfangen wurde oder nicht
empfangen werden sollte viele auch ich
mich ausgeladen er ist der repräsentant
des deutschen volkes und ich finde wir
bürger haben doch auch viel es gibt ja
auch viele flüchtlingshelfer in
deutschland sollte nicht unser
repräsentant empfangen werden von
wilders das mag ja sein aber da müssen
wir uns auch mal ein stück weit ehrlich
machen welche rolle spielt in
deutschland in diesem konflikt in der
beziehung zu den zu den russen und was
haben wir denn tatsächlich von eigenen
versäumnissen da auch aufzubringen und
worin liegen die ursachen
da müssen wir uns mal ehrlich machen und
nicht rumjammern wir geben die frage
mehr weiter an den flügel caroline
bosbach hier sehen sie das denn ich kann
beiden aussagen was abgewinnen ich
verstehe auch beides habe natürlich für
alle jedoch gedanken dazu gemacht gerade
in den letzten 24 stunden es war schon
hart das hat natürlich hin getroffen
also das was du jetzt irgendwie sagt
dass man sich als deutschland das kann
ich nicht bestätigen ich fühle mich
persönlich überhaupt nicht tangiert
es ist tatsächlich eher so dass
natürlich drängt die frage auf wem hilft
das wem hilft es in dieser situation
grad der ukraine ist die allerletzte
leaders grad gebrauchen können dass man
sagt man ja immer nett ihn jetzt aus auf
der anderen seite und das finde ich
eigentlich das wichtige signal zeigt das
ja irgendwo auch wie verzweifelt die
ukraine auf unsere zögerlichkeit
reagiert auf das wir dass wir einfach
nicht voran machen das ist er das signal
was ich daraus lesen
das finde ich ein absolut richtiges und
wichtiges argument und wir sehen das ja
gerade auch am heutigen tag wenn es um
die frage geht wie wie tief sind
eigentlich spd-politiker und frank
walter steinmeier war bis vor ein paar
jahren bevor dann bundespräsident war
klassisch spd politiker wie tief ist
diese partei verstrickt in beziehungen
zum kreml und so putin und wer sich
heute auch noch mal bilder anschaut
beispielsweise von manuela schwesig der
ministerpräsidentin von mecklenburg
vorpommern und das in bezug setzt zum
thema noch zum 2 der wird feststellen
dass es vielen spd-politikern bei
nordstream zwei rein um interessen gegen
des kreml und angeblich auch
westeuropäischen interessen das thema
osteuropa spielt er auch in aussagen von
manuela schwesig nie eine rolle und wir
wissen aber dass gerade die
osteuropäischen länder seit jahren von
nord stream zwei wannen und warnt haben
und jetzt sehen wir was passiert ist und
da kann ich die reaktion von seelen es
geht durchaus verstehen in der ukraine
hat man den eindruck diese pipeline hat
massiv dazu beigetragen
dass man russland nicht als den die das
land gesehen hat was es ist nämlich als
ein gefährliches land sondern dass man
immer versucht hat alles was an signalen
an schlechten signal aus dem kreml kam
zu übertünchen und plötzlich gibt es
einen angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine
und man gibt deutschland in gewisser
weise die mit schuld und zumindest kann
man das bei der kungelei die wir gesehen
haben zwischen sozialdemokraten und dem
kreml aus den vergangenen jahren
verstehen frank walter steinmeier hat
sich entschuldigt auch er hat ja auch
seinen freunden aus den letzten jahren
etwas revidiert aber wir kommen einmal
hier zu unserem österreichischen bürger
am tisch wie sehen sie das wie nehmen
sie das wahr ich meine es gab ja auch
ein staatsbesuch aus österreich ja auch
nicht so wahnsinnig rühmlich also wenn
ich jetzt höre dass frank walter
steinmeier versucht hatte andere
menschen andere amtsträgerin davon ab
200 ihn zu fahren das ist schon mal noch
eine charakterfrage über die debattiert
werden sollte aber grundsätzlich denke
ich mir man muss jetzt schon einen
gewissen pragmatismus auch in der
perspektive von salewski verstehen ich
glaube carlo hat auch angedeutet es geht
jetzt nicht um irgendeine
repräsentations besucher ist einfach
nicht die zeit dafür ist man das sterben
kinder das sterben menschen wenige
kilometer von hier entfernt und
verbraucht der entscheidungsträger dort
der braucht jetzt quasi nicht in den
star und schöne bilder zu machen um
irgendwann ein
zeichen der solidarität zu zeigen
sondern braucht es ganz konkrete hilfe
mehr braucht waffenlieferungen und er
braucht das maßnahmen auch innerhalb der
europäischen union getroffen werden und
das ist die gleiche kritik die man auch
an karl hammer dem österreichischen
bundeskanzler gemacht hat nämlich sich
die frage zu stellen derweil die kritik
dass er direkt nach moskau weiter genau
die gleiche thematik was bringt das wenn
ein österreichischer bundeskanzler sicht
war sie in moskau inszeniert das muss
doch klar sein dass er
instrumentalisiert wird es muss doch
klar sein dass nur der agenda von putin
hielt und das ist gleichzeitig gegenüber
der ukraine ist und wenn wir jetzt sehen
dass frank walter steinmeier quasi sich
das vorrecht nehmen wollte starts
überhaupt dorthin zu fahren um irgendwie
schon in bilder zu machen während
gleichzeitig olaf scholz und die
deutsche regierung sich davor drückt
echte solidarität zu zeigen und zwar so
wie selensky und zu kriegen ist auch
einfordert dann ist das schon etwas was
man auch entsprechend bewerten muss hier
würde ich gerne einmal rolf herrmann
noch mal in die leitung holen pauli es
ist gerade die frage aufgekommen ob
staatsbesuch überhaupt etwas bringen wie
würdest du das einschätzen boris johnson
war zum beispiel auch in kiew
ich glaube schon dass staatsbesuch etwas
bringen und wir haben ja gesehen boris
johnson sind hier große sympathien
entgegen gestoßen aber nicht weil er
sonst nice sondern weil großbritannien
von anfang an massiv waffen in die
ukraine gebracht hat und das sind waffen
die
diese stadt davor bewahrt haben
eingenommen zu werden dass ich ihn noch
sitze zum beispiel und nicht fliehen
musste oder erschossen wurde oder
festgenommen wurde von russischen
soldaten ums jetzt mal ganz hart zu
personalisieren liegt auch an den waffen
die aus großbritannien und aus den usa
hier nach kiew geliefert wurden denn das
tier gehalten wurde als statt bislang
zumindest und in den nächsten wochen
monaten wird das so sein eventuell gibt
es einen weiteren angriff geben aber
damit hatte niemand gerechnet also die
geheimdienste wir alle gesagt in 72
stunden fällt diese stadt und so weiter
und so fort und woran lag das weil
deutschland zum beispiel vor dem krieg
immer gesagt hatten waffen liefern wenn
ich das ist dann vor große provokationen
gegen putin und dann fängt er den
kriegern als er dann den krieg
angefangen habe man allen ernstes
politiker teil weil gesagt naja jetzt
waffen liefern das würde nur für eine
verlängerung des krieges führen weil das
würde dann ja bedeuten dass die ukraine
die hätten ja trotzdem keine chance
gegen die gegen die russische armee und
ähnlich weit ihr zweiter argumentiert in
richtung osten wo jetzt wieder gesagt
wird ja aber im osten haben die hat die
russische armee ja so viel mehr kräfte
und dann gewinnen die also man muss auch
einmal verstehen warum hier so viele so
wütend sind noch einmal ich verstehe
dass man sagt das war jetzt vielleicht
und lobt das war taktisch vielleicht
nicht so klug aber man darf nicht
vergessen wie sehr hier bestimmte
deutsche position und insbesondere
frankfurter stein mehr auf unverständnis
gestoßen haben muss eine korrektur
machen zur debatte steinmeier hat sich
offenbar nicht alleine selbst eingeladen
sondern es soll die idee von herrn duda
dem polnischen präsidenten gewesen sein
dass er dort mit den vier zusammen
hierher kommt das soll die initiative
gewesen sein um so
brüskierte ist der bundespräsident ich
glaube eine solche klatsche hat ein
deutsches staatsoberhaupt in den letzten
jahrzehnten noch nirgendwo kassiert ich
glaube ein besseres schlussworten zu
deiner these paar kann es heute nicht
geben pass weiter gut auf dich auf und
wir hören uns morgen abend wieder wie
jeden abend bei film nach acht
dankeschön